[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez gracias por acompañarme
iniciamos este espacio centrándonos en
los países que se convirtieron en los
pioneros en vacunar a sus ciudadanos
contra el coi 19 por un lado de esta
rusia con sus públicas 5 la inmunización
comenzó en moscú y según el kremlin son
miles las personas que han recibido la
primera dosis la segunda será aplicada
veintiún días después
inicialmente vacunaremos a personas de
grupos de alto riesgo
estos incluyen personal médico
trabajadores sociales y profesores todos
quienes están en contacto con grandes
grupos de ciudadanos son las líneas
la vacuna fue registrado oficialmente y
ha pasado dos etapas de las pruebas
clínicas ahora estamos terminando la
tercera etapa entre si en el contexto de
la pandemia y en las condiciones en las
que estábamos y no se contradice ninguna
práctica normal toluca y con normativa
también integrantes del ejército han
recibido la primera inyección aunque son
muchas las personas que esperan obtener
sus dosis según sondeos
más del 50% de la población ha dicho que
no confía en el fármaco y que no se lo
aplicaría mientras que no se publiquen
los resultados finales de las pruebas
clínicas las autoridades aseguran que la
efectividad de la vacuna es del 91 4%
para ser honesta no sé si me la pondría
porque no he leído ningunos resultados
de la vacuna sobre si funciona o no
pero estoy segura de que no hay problema
con vacunar
diferentes de probar a que la base una
ayuda a superar el virus más fácilmente
oa prevenir las enfermedades del súper
95 l
vamos ahora al reino unido donde el plan
de inmunización a gran escala se lleva a
cabo con la vacuna de los laboratorios
pzifer y bayonne tec la eficacia está
cifrada en el 95 por ciento
margaret keenan una mujer de 90 años y
william shakespeare de 81 fueron los
primeros en recibir su dosis el gobierno
británico indicó que en principio el
fármaco será aplicado a mayores de 80
años trabajadores de residencias de
personas mayores y personal médico
para empezar pensé que era una broma
para ser honesta no podía creerlo
pero sabes estoy feliz de que me hayan
vacunado y ahora espero que esto ayude a
que otras personas vengan y hagan lo que
yo hice tratar de hacer lo mejor para
deshacernos de este virus de arriba
es innovador creo podría marcar la
diferencia en nuestras vidas a partir de
ahora
[Música]
poco después de iniciar las
inmunizaciones las autoridades
sanitarias británicas emitieron una
recomendación que las personas con
historial de alergias severas no reciban
el fármaco pues en la primera jornada se
produjeron reacciones alérgicas en dos
integrantes del personal médico que
sufrieron un choque anafiláctico
asimismo recomendaron que en todos los
centros médicos donde se lleve a cabo la
vacunación haya los elementos y equipos
médicos de reanimación necesarios para
enfrentar cualquier eventualidad
damos por los ensayos clínicos muy
extensos que eso no era algo común
pero si necesitamos fortalecer nuestras
recomendaciones ahora que tuvimos esta
experiencia con un grupo vulnerable
dentro de los grupos seleccionados como
prioridad enviaremos este consejo a
terreno y medio
recordemos que hasta el momento reinó
unido- un país de 67 millones de
habitantes ha pedido 40 millones de
dosis pero esta vacuna requiere de dos
inyecciones por lo que 20 millones de
personas quedarían inmunizadas ahora
tenemos que decir que china ha señalado
que cerca de un millón de personas ya
recibieron
las vacunas experimentales desarrolladas
por la farmacéutica scinopharm como
parte del programa de uso de emergencia
autorizado por beijing además son varios
los países que ya han anunciado fechas
tentativas para iniciar los planes de
inmunización el gobierno mexicano llegó
a un acuerdo con pzifer para comprar más
de 34 millones de dosis y aseguró que
las primeras llegarán durante la tercera
semana de diciembre cuando comenzará la
vacunación se estima que este mes estén
disponibles 250 mil y que el primer
grupo en recibir la vacuna sea el
personal sanitario de cumplirse este
itinerario méxico sería la primera
nación de américa latina' en realizar
una vacunación masiva israel recibió las
primeras dosis de facer y empezará a
vacunar su población el 20 de diciembre
brasil afirmó que empezara su plan entre
enero y febrero
canadá que aprobó la vacuna de facer
anunció que recibirá las primeras dosis
al final de diciembre y emiratos árabes
unidos aprobó una de las vacunas chinas
de laboratorio scinopharm
y dejamos las vacunas pero vamos a japón
donde se han implementado máquinas
esterilizadoras para limpiar los libros
en las bibliotecas y tratar de darle
confianza a las personas para que no
dejen de asistir a estos lugares a causa
del coi 19 se trata de artefactos que
usan luz ultravioleta y en 30 segundos
limpian los libros para muchas personas
se trata de una novedad aunque estas
máquinas ya se usaban en algunas
bibliotecas del país de acuerdo con
estudios realizados algunas cepas del
nuevo coronavirus pueden vivir sólo unos
minutos en el papel mientras que otras
duran hasta cinco días y no estoy segura
de qué tan efectivo es pero es mejor que
nada y es divertido de ver y con el
tomate
me siento aliviado porque esteriliza los
libros pero no sé si realmente es
efectivo
y finalizamos este espacio hablando de
una cápsula de la sonda nipona hayabusa
2 que ya se encuentra en japón tras
haber aterrizado en australia el domingo
6 de diciembre la cápsula que contiene
arena del asteroide riega las muestras
fueron recolectadas el año pasado y
durante lo que queda de este año y a lo
largo de 2021 los científicos de la
agencia de exploración aeroespacial de
japón las estudiarán y buscarán señales
que indiquen cómo se formó el sistema
solar
la sonda continuará en el espacio para
completar otra misión así concluimos
esta crónica a ustedes muchas gracias
por su compañía continúen con nosotros
aquí en france 24
[Música]